>> IT'S VERY DANGEROUS, CHUCK,
BECAUSE A LOT OF WHAT YOU'RE SEE
FRANKLY, ARE ATTACKS ON SCIENCE,
BECAUSE ALL OF THE THINGS THAT I
HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT CONSISTENTLY
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING HAVE
BEEN FUNDAMENTALLY BASED ON
SCIENCE.
SOMETIMES THOSE THINGS WERE
INCONVENIENT TRUTHS FOR PEOPLE,
AND THERE WAS PUSHBACK AGAINST
ME, SO IF YOU ARE TRYING TO GET
AT ME AS A PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIAL AND A SCIENTIST, YOU
REALLY ARE ATTACKING NOT ONLY
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI, YOU'RE
ATTACKING SCIENCE, AND ANYBODY
THAT LOOKS AT WHAT'S GOING ON
CLEARLY SEES THAT.
YOU HAVE TO BE ASLEEP NOT TO SEE
THAT.
BRIAN:  WHAT AN INSULT.
LET'S BRING IN TUCKER CARLSON,
HOST OF TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT
AND HE'S GOT ANOTHER SPECIAL ON
THE TUCKER CARLSON ORIGINALS BUT
WE GOT TO GET YOU TO COMMENT ON
THIS.
I KNOW YOU HAD THIS , TUCKER,
THANKS FOR  GETTING UP.
>> HELLO.
>> GOOD MORNING.
BRIAN:  YOU HAVE TO BE ASLEEP IF
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
CRITICISM OF HIM, IS
CRITICIZING SCIENCE.
>> THIS IS A PERFECT WHAT WE
JUST LIVED THROUGH FOR THE PAST
YEAR AND A HALF, SO HERE, FAUCI
IMAGINES A COUPLE THINGS, FIRST
OF ALL, HE REFERS TO HIMSELF IN
THE THIRD PERSON.
BRIAN:  IT'S BIZARRE.
>> IT IS BIZARRE AND SECOND HE
IMAGINES THAT SINCERE QUESTIONS
ARE THE SAME AS CRITICISM AND HE
IMAGINES THAT QUESTIONING
SCIENCE ATTACKING SCIENCE.
SCIENCE IS NOT A BOOK THAT YOU
CHECK OUT OF THE LIBRARY OR
LOOK UP ON WIKIPEDIA.
SCIENCE IS A WAY OF THINKING AND
IT BEGINS WITH DEEP SKEPTICISM
ABOUT WHAT WE THINK WE KNOW.
YOU COMMIT SCIENCE WHEN YOU TAKE
NOTHING FOR GRANTED, WHEN YOU
ASK HARD QUESTIONS.
WE THINK THIS WORKS, HOW DO WE
KNOW THAT IT WORKS?
THAT'S WHAT SCIENCE IS, SO HERE
IS A GUY WHO REPRESENTS SCIENCE,
WHO IMAGINES THAT QUESTIONS ARE
AN  ATTACK ON SCIENCE.
HE'S INSTANTLY DISQUALIFIED
HIMSELF AS A SCIENTIST, IN
ADDITION TO REVEALING THAT HE'S
GOT WEIRD LEWIS XIV TENDENCIES,
I AM SCIENCE?
NO YOU'RE NOT.
YOU'RE A FEDERAL BUREAUCRAT.
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS, DO MASKS
WORK, TELL US THE TRUTH, WHERE
IS THE STUDY?
HOW DO YOU KNOW THEY WORK?
THAT IS SCIENCE, THOSE QUESTIONS
WE COMMIT YOUR SCIEN